[Music]
the Powerpuff Girls was a super popular
show that debuted in 1998 but it wasn't
always a wholesome show about little
girls who fight crime keep watching to
find out all the dark secrets about the
Powerpuff Girls feeling nostalgic
subscribe to the things for more awesome
nostalgia videos and now it's time for
ten dark secrets about the Powerpuff
Girls creepy men the Powerpuff Girls are
three sisters who were created in a lab
by a professor
they are kindergarten age but they fight
crime like any other superhero and in
the crime-fighting business they
encounter a lot of creepy men one of the
villains is lynnie baxter the show
passes him off as a super fan of the
Powerpuff Girls
but even Buttercup realizes he's a total
creep he's got a collection of Powerpuff
memorabilia and buttercup calls it seven
kinds of creepy she's totally right
lynnie Baxter is so obsessed but he
lures the girls and tries to kidnap them
he's a grown man
kidnapping little girls and that's just
wrong on so many levels the mayor of
Townsville is also pretty creepy in one
episode he licks his pet cat we're
pretty sure kids totally missed this
very adult joke at least we sure hope so
and in the Powerpuff Girls creepiness
starts young the girls have a total
sadistic creep in their kindergarten
class mitch is a mean bully he spends a
ton of time tormenting the class hamster
it's really pretty disturbing we bet he
grows up to be a villain the devil is in
the details
one of the main villains in the
Powerpuff Girls is him yep his name is
just him and if you take a close look
you might think he looks a little
familiar him is based on traditional art
of the devil he's red with pointed ears
creepy claws like a lobster he even has
the same alias as the devil king of
darkness but the real shocking thing
about him is how he dresses him wears a
red mini dress with pink frills in a
black leather belt
he's got knee-high high-heeled boots and
he appears to wear a pink blush on his
cheeks we're the creators of the show
trying to be funny or were they
expressing their opinions either way
this would not fly in today's cartoons
and
is definitely another one of those
creepy men we talked about he uses a lot
of psychological manipulation and preys
on bubbles naive personality he's
definitely the most deranged villain in
the Powerpuff Girls retro references
although the Powerpuff Girls was a late
1990s hit show
there are many throw backs to the 1950s
and 1960s the whole show is supposed to
have a very retro superhero vibe a lot
of the cheesiness is a throwback to the
original Batman TV show from the 60s
it's campy and over-the-top and the
villains ride the fine line between
crazy and comical also the mayor of
Townsville has a fancy office that is
supposed to look like the office of
Gotham's Commissioner Gordon from the
original TV series him is also a tribute
to another 1960s character the show's
creator craig mccracken revealed that
tim was inspired by a character named
chief blue meanie he was in the very
strange animated Beatles film Yellow
Submarine from 1968 the Yellow Submarine
is a weird cult classic and has a lot of
the same strangeness that we get in the
Powerpuff Girls
even the Powerpuff Girls home is
inspired by an old film it is based on
the home in the 1958 French film monocle
it's pretty cool that this movie is
referenced in the Powerpuff Girls
because it won the Oscar for Best
Foreign Film in 1959
who knew Powerpuff Girls had so much
class where in the world is Townsville
there's a lot of speculation about the
location of Townsville and the show
never reveals exactly where it is or
does it
the narrator starts every episode with
the city of Townsville where is this
fictional place where kindergarteners
fight supervillains the answer to the
location is in the 2002 episode him
diddle-diddle in this episode him leads
the Powerpuff Girls on a scavenger hunt
the girls believe they are trying to
solve the series of riddles to save
professor utonium but really him is just
messing with them he requires them to go
somewhere without line and stop two
trains from colliding they encountered
two miss Keens
one tells the truth and the other tells
a lie in a scene reminiscent of the
labyrinth then they have to take the
SATs amazingly bubbles got a really high
score even though she's in kindergarten
finally they have coordinates to find
these coordinates are 32 degrees north
and 212 degrees west
if you
put these into real coordinates
Townsville is supposedly located in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean so it's safe
to say Townsville is a very made-up
place punishment most foul Buttercup
blossom and bubbles may be adorable
little girls but they are also pretty
ruthless when it comes to crime fighting
in one episode the mayor offers the
girls candy as a reward they become
addicted and attack mojo really badly
seriously
they leave his brain exposed that's not
exactly kid-friendly crime-fighting
another criminal the Sandman meets an
even worse fate at the hands of the
Powerpuff Girls The Sandman tries to
make everyone sleep forever because he's
exhausted the Powerpuff Girls give him a
nightmare so terrifying he never sleeps
again
you can't live long with no sleep that's
an awful punishment and it's not just
the Powerpuff Girls that are ruthless
they're criminals aren't always
family-friendly either one time a zombie
magician tries to end blossom's life in
a spiked coffin after mistaking her for
the girl who led him to his fate and
then there's the episode set in the
future which looks like something from
Mad Max instead of a kid's cartoon
adults original concept the Powerpuff
Girls didn't always have such a cutesy
name they had a way more adult sounding
name but the original concept was more
or less the same the show's creator
craig mccracken originally had a bad
word in the title is something you would
open a can of if you were fighting
someone Cartoon Network made him change
the name to Powerpuff it's a pretty
great change because it sounds like a
dainty powder puff but really they are
totally tuff triplets we couldn't
imagine them with such a vulgar name
especially since they are 5 years old
the original episode was a three minute
short film McCracken created at CalArts
in it the girls face the amoeba boys
they fried the boys on the surface of
the Sun talk about brutal Cartoon
Network made McCracken tone it down
but he's still left in some pretty
intense stuff these kindergarteners are
way more mature think that's a dark
secret stay tuned to find out what they
don't want you to know sedusa sedusa is
every occur until n' in the Powerpuff
Girls she goes undercover and uses
aliases a lot and she's definitely meant
for more mature audiences one time she
is disguised as miss bellum she tries to
get the mayor to take the night off she
has a very adult scene where she helps
the mayor sharpen his pencil and it's
more than just suggestive the mayor
enjoys it way too much we can't believe
this is in a cartoon meant for kids
later blossom dresses up as miss bellum
by stuffing her shirt with stuffed
animals in another episode she is
disguised as I'm a good lady and goes on
a date with the professor Buttercup
sticks something in his pocket before
the date it's hinting that it's
something to keep him from having
anymore let's just say accidents it's
pretty much a guarantee that whenever
sedusa is involved things are going to
get inappropriate
we understand that she's a total femme
fatale but does that really belong in a
kid show maybe she's just there to make
the adults laugh instead no girls
allowed it's not that hard to see all
the girl power in this classic cartoon
but there is one episode in particular
that really shows the three sisters
facing misogyny and they beat that just
like it was another villain in the
episode members only the Powerpuff Girls
aspire to join the association of
world's supermen they pass all their
tests easily feeding several famous
superheroes at competitions but then the
leader of the Association gives a super
anti girl speech the girls aren't
allowed in because they are girls they
even talk about how they don't have mom
but their dad does all the work of both
mom and dad the Association doesn't like
this they believe that men should do
certain things and women should do
others but then the Powerpuff Girls end
it by saving the entire association of
world supermen and they change their
tune cartoons may try not to get too
political but it's hard to deny the
feminist overtones in this episode we
love that the Powerpuff Girls are even
better than all the other superheroes
and we love that their dad does the
cooking and the laundry the Rowdyruff
Boys are a reoccurring group on the
Powerpuff Girls they are pretty similar
to the girls even their names start with
the letter B but they are created by
Mojo Jojo mojo Trix professor utonium
into giving him the recipe the professor
used to create the Powerpuff Girls and
then mojo made it more masculine using
armpit hair snails and a puppy dog tail
these boys have a lot of weakness and
their masculinity is definitely fragile
all the Powerpuff Girls have to do to
defeat them is kiss them but later hen
gives them a cootie shot after the shot
kisses make them bigger and stronger now
they have to have their masculinity
threatened to be defeated when they are
embarrassed or insulted the Rowdyruff
Boys shrink in size the Powerpuff Girls
defeat them by doing embarrassing things
to them like baby them and pull down
their pants this is definitely a joke
about other things that are small when
masculinity is threatened the Rowdyruff
Boys are bullies but we also don't
recommend doing the things that girls do
to them in retaliation reboot
controversy and now it's time for the
big secret the creators of the Powerpuff
Girls don't want you to know you might
know that the Powerpuff Girls show was
rebooted in 2016 it's currently on its
third season well not everyone was
excited about this when the new voice
actors were announced the original voice
actors were super upset tear is strong
the voice of the original bubbles
tweeted I don't remember ordering a stab
in the heart today the original
Buttercup Elisabeth daily also was not
happy Kathy kavadi knee the original
blossom was a lot more diplomatic
she wished the new girls well but she
said it hurt her heart not to be recast
the original Mojo Jojo professor utonium
and the mayor did return however we
aren't sure why they decided to pick all
new girls to voice the crime-fighting
sisters but we think the new voices and
the original voices are incredible the
new show is obviously doing well even
with the new voice actor controversy
it's already up to 86 episodes do you
think they should have cast the original
voice actors for the Powerpuff Girls let
us know in the comments those are the 10
dark secrets about the Powerpuff Girls
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things
[Music]
[Music]